[Música]
[Aplausos]
todo comenzó hace 60 años
la muda
caminaba hacia un cruce en un lugar
llamado 2 con ya la menor de 16 hermanos
tenía que vender chicharrones todos los
días porque su familia había sido
desplazada de la violencia después de
una onda que había atacado el carmen de
bolívar la muda además de eso era
llamada así porque cuando vendía
chicharrones se hacía la que no hablaba
para poder contar la plata de todos sus
hermanos esta persona a los nueve años
dejó de trabajar en la venta de
chicharrones familiar y se fue a
trabajar como empleada del servicio lo
cual sólo duró un día con esta plata
compro ropa interior y después de
comprar esta ropa interior comenzó a
vender la puerta puerta esa ropa
interior que vendió puerta a puerta la
llevó a tener un pequeño almacén en este
pueblo que les mencioné que se llama
baskonia
la boda terminó teniendo un montón de
negocios estos negocios se convirtieron
en una fábrica de confecciones que
terminó vendiendo para colombia y el
mundo más de 120 mil prendas al mes con
tercera de primaria y con 62 años la
muda mi abuela me enseñó acerca de la
capacidad que tienen las personas para
mover las estrellas
y de eso vamos a hablar el pensamiento
plástico que es la capacidad que todos
nosotros tenemos para cambiar la
realidad si solo nos esforzamos por
entender cómo podemos acabar con
aquellas cosas que nos enseñaron de
pequeños y transformar desde ahí toda la
realidad que somos hace cinco años aquí
en cúcuta cuando empecé a emprender
tenía un montón de sueños y una cita con
el destino en una entidad del gobierno
que da 100 millones de pesos todos los
años para que los emprendedores puedan
desarrollar sus proyectos esa cita con
el destino que duró cinco minutos
terminó en una conversación muy práctica
su empresa no va a funcionar lo va a
lograr seis meses y después de esos seis
meses para que ver
resulta que tenía razón
fueron dos años y medio sin facturar
absolutamente nada perdiendo la
absolutamente todo con extorsiones
mirándome de ciudad cada dos meses y
comiendo durante seis meses y 29 días
pan con agua todos los días una vez al
día durmiendo en el piso y mirando hacia
el horizonte en un pequeño apartamento
en bogotá hacia la torre colpatria
deseando trabajar ahí alguna vez
esa persona de hace cinco años comenzó a
entender que su realidad no podía ser
otra que la que terminara construyendo
después de pensar de la forma más
práctica posible maneras para aprovechar
el talento que tenía
la verdad lo único que yo sabía hacer
era hablar cha cha y fue lo que comencé
a aprovechar
eso que comienza a aprovechar se
convirtió una vaga idea de éxito una
idea de éxito que me llevaba a tratar de
dar clases de cómo hablar en público a
personas mucho mayores que yo que de
alguna forma podrían aprender de mí esa
capacidad que tenía para poder decir
cosas que ellos no sabían decir
después y atendiendo un poco todo esto
comencé a conocer personas entonces
llegaron a organizaciones que comenzaron
a transformar mi vida y me comenzaron a
presentar contactos desde la comisión de
juventud del congreso de la república
comenzamos a entender cómo los jóvenes
del país podían ser los protagonistas de
esa nueva colombia y entonces eliminamos
el requisito obligatoria de la libreta
militar para que las personas pudiesen
graduarse después comenzamos a entender
que una de las herramientas para
eliminar el microtráfico en el país era
permitir que algunas personas llevaron
una dosis mínima y que desde ahí se
pudiese transformar la mentalidad y la
cultura de las personas posterior a eso
con la primera ley de empleo
desarrollamos una estrategia para que
los primeros cinco años las personas en
el país pudiesen tener incentivos
tributarios y el estatuto de ciudadanía
juvenil permitió que los jóvenes menores
de 28 años pudiesen aspirar mínimo
durante un 30% en las listas al congreso
de la república de colombia
pastor decirme en algún momento que no
era capaz de sacar adelante una empresa
para poder hacer que mi corazón y mi
cabeza se acelerara y desde esa
capacidad de pensar comenzar a construir
una realidad que era imposible para un
montón de personas más de 100 proyectos
dos premios mundiales y siete países
después estamos transformando el mundo
con algo que nos permite entender la
realidad de una manera muy muy distinta
que nos permite conocer a las personas
desde tres elementos fundamentales que
consideramos que componen el pensamiento
plástico esos elementos fundamentales
quieren hacer el aprendizaje como primer
factor para poder definir cuando una
persona es capaz de transformar o no su
realidad y ese aprendizaje que nosotros
entendemos desde ahí es lo que nos
permite aproximarnos a formas nuevas de
entender el mundo un aprendizaje que no
necesariamente es técnico que no
necesariamente es teórico que no
necesariamente tiene que ser desde la
academia
que viene desde el segundo elemento del
pensamiento plástico al que llamamos
circunstancias estas circunstancias que
nos permiten hacer que una persona tenga
valor no por cuánto tiene no por cuántos
viajes ha hecho ni por el que familia
proviene una persona tiene valor por
toda esa historia de vida que le permite
entenderse y transformarse todos los
días
como tercer elemento del pensamiento
plástico encontramos las influencias y
ese es elemento natural de los seres
humanos que nos permiten relacionarnos
que nos permite conocer a otros y que
desde ese conocimiento nos permite hacer
que toda nuestra vida cambie estas
relaciones o contactos o como los
queramos llamar que están permitiendo
que en el mundo un grupo de jóvenes
pueda mover las estrellas hoy cuatro
empresas se unieron para que en todos
los países del mundo podamos hacer
turismo con propósito teníamos 40
hoteles por construir hoy ya son 37 y
estamos haciendo que 350 familias y
además 90 mil tortugas puedan llegar al
mar todos los años la pregunta es cuál
es el elemento diferente en la realidad
que tuvo mi abuela o que tuve yo para
poder transformarla
no es ningún otro que el gran principio
del tau el sabio gobierna las estrellas
y el necio las obedece los invito a
mover su estrella gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]